what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down more of the strongest
types of magic also known as magic
attributes in black clover in the
previous installment of this video
series I said that I would make a part 2
based on your suggestions if that video
got over 3000 likes as of the making of
this video that video has over 7,000
likes so as promised here is part 2 just
like last time I will be examining each
magic types abilities strengths
weaknesses and future potential to be
clear this is not an exhaustive list or
a countdown this is a detailed analysis
of what I believe to be some of the
strongest and most overpowered magic
types in black clover
if you end up enjoying this video and
you want to see me make a part 3 just
leave a like subscribe and give me your
suggestions for which magic types to
cover in the next video down in the
comments below if we can get over 4,000
likes on this video part 3 will be made
you can also give me your suggestions on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
finally this video might contain some
black clover manga spoilers the black
hole random is actually pretty close to
the manga but depending on when you're
watching this video you might run into a
few spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned by far the
most requested magic type in the
comments of the previous video was the
incredible time' magic used by the
wizard King at Julius Noah chrono just
as the name suggests time magic enables
its user to manipulate time and this
includes stopping time speeding up time
slowing down time and even reversing
time Julius is the only known user of
time magic in the world of black lover
and his grimoire is interesting because
it doesn't have book covers it's
basically a raid at our grimoire because
it's minka anyway time magic has many
diverse applications we've seen Julius
using time magic to restrain his
opponents by basically freezing them
inside
I'm Lou and on top of restraining
opponents time magic can also be used to
trap magic spells inside a time loop
thereby negating their effectiveness
this works on even the fastest types of
magic such as light magic in the past
we've also seen Julia's healing himself
by reversing his own time essentially
Julius has the ability to rewind time in
order to heal his injuries
much like Aerys quark rewind was able to
do for Deku in boku no hero during his
fight against Patri julius's time magic
is showcased in great detail julius
reveals that he was born with a magic
that quote steals the future but his
ultimate goal is to create a new future
without discrimination according to
julius time magic allows him to
essentially steal the time of others and
store it away so that he can use it at a
later date during the Patri fight we saw
some truly impressive techniques from
julius for example we saw that he can
combine mana zone with the acceleration
of time in order to read the future flow
of mana this allows them to gain very
short glimpses into the future a
technique that is incredibly useful in
any type of battle just imagine being in
a fight and being able to tell why your
opponent will do before he even does it
the advantage that such a technique
provides in battle is massive even
though light magic is arguably the
single fastest magic attribute in the
world while fighting Julius Patri
realized that even his light magic
combined with a 4-leaf grimoire was
simply no match for Julius and his time
magic Julius was just too strong for
poetry and Patri knew it but while he
was fighting Patri Julius wasn't going
all-out he was trying to restrain poetry
without killing him because he knew that
Pachi was possessing the body of William
von Jets Patri saw that this was the
case and he also knew that Julius as the
wizard King had a duty to protect all
the citizens of the clover kingdom so
Patri took advantage of this by using
his light magic spell called arrows of
judgment to launch a massive attack on
the entire Capitol thousands of lives
were suddenly put in direct
danger and this prompted Julius to use
his spell called chrono Anastasis
to reverse the time of Patras arrows of
judgment and essentially negate the
deadly light magic before it could hurt
the innocent people of the capital
however the combination of Julia's going
easy on pachi because he doesn't want to
kill him and of Julius being distracted
by the need to protect the citizens of
the clover kingdom allowed Patri to land
a decisive blow on Julius pacci was able
to stab Julius through the chest with
his light sword an act that seemingly
kills Julius but as we learn later
Julius was able to store 13 years worth
of time inside the strange star-shaped
tattoo on his forehead after his death
Julius is able to use time magic to
bring himself back to life as a 13 year
old boy although he is not as strong as
he once was and although his grimoire
has reverted back to being just a single
page the resurrected Julia still has the
same personality and memories of the
original Julius
when we combine his ability to
manipulate time in various different
ways with his ability to steal and store
time in order to literally bring himself
back from the dead it is easy to see
that Julius is time magic is one of the
most powerful magic attributes in the
entire series although Julius strength
is no longer at its peak now that he has
been resurrected as a 13 year old the
potential time magic is truly enormous
and I can't wait to learn more about
this incredible magic attribute as the
story continues next up let's talk about
dream magic a magic type used by the
sleepy witch who also happens to be the
captain of the coral peacock squad
Dorothy Unsworth dream magic is uniquely
cool and definitely one of my personal
favorite magic types using her grimoire
Dorothy can release a magical mist that
can bring everything it touches into a
dreamlike world called glamour world
this includes people and large and small
inorganic materials basically everything
and everyone within a specific area the
dream world is an endless boundless
plane of existence that is separate from
the real world and that is controlled by
the dream match
user inside the dream world the user can
create literally anything that she
imagines she can use any magic type and
she possesses virtually unlimited
amounts of magic in some ways the dream
magic spell glamour world gives its user
godlike powers over anyone who happens
to be trapped inside that world with her
other mages who are trapped inside this
world are still able to use their own
magic but that's a small consolation
when you consider the godlike powers and
abilities that Dorothy possesses
including the ability to literally just
imagine into existence anything and
everything that she wishes on top of all
of that those who are trapped inside the
dreamlike glamour world will become
drowsier and drowsier the longer they
stay trapped inside and if they fall
asleep inside this dream world they will
die in real life during the battle
between the elf Reve who was possessing
Dorothy's body and several of the black
bulls and Sally Reve succeeds and
trapping Sally and the black bulls
inside glamour world if not for
Vanessa's incredibly Opie red thread of
fate which helped the black bulls and
Sally evade the deadly attacks that were
being thrown their way everyone trapped
inside glamour world at that time would
have been destroyed very quickly but as
powerful as dream magic is it does have
some weaknesses first of all in order to
use it effectively you have to make sure
that your opponent is trapped inside
glamour world in the first place if your
opponent can somehow avoid being trapped
inside that world then the user of dream
magic will have to fight in the real
world now with that said it is entirely
possible that dream magic does possess
spells that are effective in the real
world
our knowledge of dream magic is still
very limited and glamour world is the
only major dream magic spell that we
have seen so far we have to assume that
other spells with other effects could
also exist and may be revealed in the
future but the spell glamour world
itself also has a few other limitations
for one thing once the user of dream
magic manifests something inside the
dream world these creations will have
the same properties as they would have
in the real
world so for example if the user of
dream magic wishes into existence a
bunch of gasoline and then proceeds to
wish into existence a burning flame the
flame will ignite the gasoline and a
fire will break out whether the user
wants this to happen or not furthermore
anything that the dream magic user
thinks of will be manifested inside
glamor world so she can actually be
manipulated into manifesting things that
she doesn't necessarily want to manifest
for example during the fight between Rev
and the black bulls and Sally Sally
takes advantage of the fact that
anything Rev thinks of is manifested in
order to trick her into manifesting an
exit from glamour world rev couldn't
just erase the exit after already
creating it but she was able to create
chains around the exit sealing it shut
Sally and the black bulls then go on to
trick rev into thinking about the real
Dorothy Unsworth the original dream
magic user and this thought actually
awakens Dorothy inside the dream world
the spell glamour world could not handle
the dreams of two different users
colliding and it collapsed in on itself
freeing the black bulls and Sally
so the elf Reve failed in defeating them
but only because the real Dorothy
managed to foil her plans and even
though Sally succeeded in tricking rev
into manifesting things and people that
she didn't want to we have to remember
that Dorothy herself is a far more
experienced and skilled user of dream
magic than the elf rev it is quite
possible that the real Dorothy would be
far more difficult to trick than Rev was
so that means that dream magic might be
even more powerful than we actually
realize in Chapter 222 we also learned
that Dorothy is able to escape the
effects of a demon curse by bringing
Noel in to glamour world because glamour
world is separate from the real world
dorothy is able to tell Noel about
Meggie Kula and the curse that the demon
placed on her mother ah CA Silva without
triggering the curse dream magic is
obviously an incredibly powerful magic
that gives its user godlike powers under
the right circumstances and although in
the only real dream magic related fight
that we've seen the black balls and
Sally managed to
feed the elf Rev this was only because
Rev was an inexperienced the dream magic
user and because the real Dorothy was
able to show up and cause glamour world
to collapse and that is why I had to
include three magic in this video we
still haven't seen the true potential of
this incredible magic type and it is
likely that there is a lot more to this
power that we are yet to discover and
now let's talk about the one and only
painting magic used by the captain of
the azure deer squad and the youngest
magic knight captain in the history of
magic knight captain's the 19 year-old
real Guam OTA this incredible Opie magic
allows the user to literally bring his
paintings to life using a paintbrush
will can create anything he wishes
including any element or magic attribute
for example the spell painting magic did
Tom Pet of Fire and Ice allows real to
create two whirlwinds one made up of
fire and the other made up of water so
it's as if real is able to use both fire
magic and water magic at the same time
when in reality he was just able to
paint them both into existence
using painting magic real can also
manifest various powerful monsters and
magic creatures into existence just by
drawing them and he can then send those
creatures to fight his opponents we've
seen this with painting magic spells
like phantom dragon guavas shout suitors
and giant strong-armed gods play and
four-headed Lindwurm rill can also trap
his opponents inside his paintings as he
does to gweld raposo with the spell
painting magic spring of restriction
painting magic spells can also be
extremely powerful when used in
combination with other magic attributes
to form compound magic spells a powerful
example of this was compound magic
elemental quintet a combo spell used by
five elves including Lyra the elf who
had possessed rill much like dream magic
allows its user to manifest anything
that you can imagine inside the dream
world just by thinking it painting magic
allows its user to manifest anything
that he can imagine in the real world
just by painting it this includes
and objects powerful magical creatures
and practically any magic attribute and
element this means that no matter who is
going up against rill rill can use
painting magic to gain an advantage over
his opponent by using the magic
attribute that would be the most
effective against his opponents magic
so if rills opponent uses fire magic
real can paint water magic and use it
against the opponent if the opponent
uses plant magic real can paint fire
magic and use it against his opponent
and so on it goes without saying that
reals magic is so freakin opie and so
far the only real disadvantages of
painting magic that we've seen are
related to not being able to control the
immense power that this magic produces
on multiple occasions real lost track of
his own power and created spells that
were too difficult to control which
demonstrates just how powerful painting
magic truly is and we can assume that as
the young rill perfects his use of
painting magic he will become even
stronger in the future
painting magic has an advantage over
dream magic because it can be used in
the real world while both magic types
give its user incredible godlike powers
of creation the user of dream magic has
to trap her opponents inside of glamour
world first while rill can just use his
magic in the real world with that said
if rill does end up trapped inside
glamour world the dream magic user has
the advantage because dream magic is
faster than painting magic
although rails painting is definitely
fast dream magic allows the user to
manifest things just by thinking them
and just thinking about something in
order to make it appear is faster than
having to actually paint something into
existence with that said real doesn't
need to trap his opponents in a
fantastical dream world in order to use
his magic and at least as far as we know
right now dream magic does require that
extra step overall I would say that time
magic is the strongest magic out of the
three
even though dream magic and painting
magic give the users godlike powers of
creation time magics ability to speed up
time slow down enemy spells and even see
glimpses of the future would prove
effective against both dream magic and
painting magic even if he had been
trapped inside a glamour world the time
magic user would still have the ability
to use his time magic and the skill the
time magic user like Julius would likely
be able to escape glamour world either
by outpacing and overwhelming Dorothy or
by somehow reversing glamour world's
time in order to dissolve it outright
and of course as great as painting magic
is julius's time manipulation would
allow him to slow down and reverse the
effects of even the most powerful
painting magic spells so while all three
of these magic attributes are extremely
Opie and some of the strongest magic
types in the entire black holder series
if I had to choose which of the three is
the strongest I would have to go with
time magic especially when it is wielded
by someone as skilled as the wizard King
Julius but let me know what you guys
think do you agree with me that time
magic is the strongest of the three and
if you could pick any of these three
magic attributes for yourself which one
would you choose
finally which other overpowered magic
types and black clovers should I cover
next hit me up down in the comments if
we can hit 4,000 likes on this video
part three will be made very soon if you
happen to be new to anime uproar or you
just still haven't subscribed be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications and feel
free to hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime out
pro patrons for supporting our work and
making these videos possible with all
the constant problems on YouTube patron
support is more important than ever
thank you guys so much
first and foremost a special thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including
Ingrid ah
Colin Adam the world Steelers the school
bus Tyson Kadena acquired respect and
Pat a heffa and I can't forget our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings Eldridge fitted ala beat
alpha do Anatoli Cassatt's ki on hell
Cruz team Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan
Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy
Vargas Shawn
dark Joe Stanton JCCC wakka Barry Gucci
and Jessica Calif bomb if you enjoy our
videos and you think that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]